I got you this because you know our boy
got benched he got put on IR
who who our boy who had to bow out of
you know Mr Olympia oh I know that's
what that's what I was going to say yeah
we have a lot of Mr Olympia to catch up
on yeah um so unfortunately Nick Walker
the mutant our [__] guy tore his
hamstring or something couldn't compete
he looks like like the The Rock Pokemon
yeah Machamp yeah he looks like Machamp
yeah no I was thinking uh Geo Geodude
Geodude some reason geod dude search
Geodude that's what he looks like yeah I
mean he could pass for a a
Machoke um so and then you know it was a
it was a very um
contested controversial result because
won yeah he won the um I don't really
know what I'm still learning like the
differences between the there's like an
overall and then there's a classic
physique so SE bomb won the classic
physique it's like his fourth in a row
or something like that got it and the
overall is usually the one where the
bigger
guys the uh you know the mutants the
absolute mutants that's the one that
they usually compete in right so last
year it was that guy huie chupin or
whatever yeah and then this year another
dude won but like all of his comments
are just like should have been hadie
yeah this Dude Looks Like Machoke down
to the haircut that that picture is
insan insane yeah pull up look at this
[__] his lats what is this pull up
Machoke real quick pull up
Machoke down to the haircut look at the
haircut yeah see but I don't know
anything about bodybuilding or like the
technical so if you read the comments
everyone's like you know they go into
these super Niche things they're like
his upper rear
dadum is like way more mature you're
like what the [__] is that he's like you
know hot you know lunsford's got to work
on his like side quad pose M and it's
just fascinating to me all this stuff is
there a video expl yo this pose seems as
if they're all going to [__] themselves
right now yeah the dude nothing like
what's the word perturbs perturbs
perturbs or like Anno like grosses me
out like these guys' ass H yeah like
zero fat like the cheeks got to have
some fat in them you know just just pure
that's a muscly cheek right there I was
just thinking of a stupid ass pun what
perturbs being a rate of speed you know
three corns per
turs rate of food per [__] nice anyways
yeah what what about it
like is it just cuz they look like
marshmallows from far away yeah yeah
yeah they look like a s'more yeah like
like find a video
uh I mean I don't know I'm not going to
make you search bodybuilder ass but yeah
like that's just looks weird right
who dude cheeks are supposed to have a
little bit of cushion on them you know
that's
disgusting what the hell they got
kneecaps on the back they got knee ass
kneecap
ass that's a if you're if you're
listening on audio you're missing out
and you're a [__]
idiot take that to work saying now that
they ass per weird right definitely
perturbs me it looks like a bus driver's
[Laughter]
head I've seen many of bus drivers with
that neck yeah and that
forehead man does your ass go back to
normal if you just stop yeah because
they're like 1% body fat so as soon as
they like get a little fat on their body
again is that what your ass looks like
beneath yeah so that's that's regular
that's that's just
ass that's just straight up ass so
that's true ass it's
ass wow yo this is ass yo this is
ass this is ass that Dude Looks
fossilized you know that the black and
white photo looks like that classic
pterodactyl print look up the
discovery of the pterodactyl or whatever
just imprinted into sand dude do they
even have but
holes like it wouldn't surprise me if
this was like if this was just like
Smooth like yeah and you know what I
don't ever want to hear anyone claim
they got a turd cutter this is a turd
cutter this is a big turd
cutter yeah dude this thing is like
squeezing it out yeah this is
toothpasting so I think we should do
bodybuilding okay I think we should Cody
and Noel do a bodybuilding show and we
spend eight months yeah I was going to
say it's a 12 month series like we sign
up for a show at the end of La next year
and we train like [__] crazy we get a
coach what show could we even get big
enough there are tons of local body
building shows you can just like join
them I'm pretty sure but what are the
weight
classes yeah we'd be in the we'd
probably be in the featherweight
division look up weight classes for
bodybuilding I don't think there's
weight classes
or or maybe it's by
height no cuz there are 58 guys that are
wider than us weight classes let's punch
in on that oh it's just like
fighting okay I think our best bet cuz
you know in fighting you always go way
below what you walk around at yeah we
should go to bantamweight 143 I don't
think I could how would we gain how
would I gain muscle and get down to that
weight have to lose every ounce of body
body fat that's how we I guess is the
point yeah that's what they do yeah so
we wanton an ass like that I mean I
guess that's that's the ultimate test oh
my God man in eight months 8 to 12
months we have to shoot an episode where
we turn
around and drop trow and our asses look
like that yeah I just realized he has
got his thong beneath his walrus
yeah whoa is that his [__] right in
the middle you think that's the hole
yeah he's showing
hole imagine just the tiny little [__]
that comes out of
that it's not even a cutter it's like a
do they even [__] does their yeah does
their body just absorb every single
ounce of yeah they probably don't eat
enough to
[__] we get to lose our [__] in the
process yeah that literally looks like
his [__] just
grew grew out out of you know what I
mean like they peeled back the they went
like
this now the thick part is on the inside
and the [__] part is on the outside
just stretched you know what I mean
exactly
whoa I don't man I think I I think i'
die I think we should do it if we ate
the amount of food required we die yeah
I have sticky blood so you would have
you you'd have trouble eating enough and
I would have to eat less yeah yeah if I
saw a table full of chicken I think I
put a gun to my
head ah I'm down to try for a month just
to see if I could survive actually no I
think it would be fun honestly you
probably need a couple months for a show
no it would it it would definitely be
fun it be St we' do it all Natty oh then
I'm
losing yeah but I'm getting I'm getting
46 we're but I don't think we're
competing against each other I think
we're both going to lose in the show
it's not about that it's just about like
getting jacked enough to like even stand
on the stage right that'd be so cringe
why just us up there just know but like
same bodies as we have now yeah eight
months down the road like I mean we
tried I didn't really try actually yeah
let's go into it like Dylan danis let's
just not exact at all exactly just [__]
it yeah I going just be me yeah yeah
dude